yeah but a b if we're going to have a  conversation a dialogue man we don't  need to say at this point you know what  do you want me to call you dog your  name's Antonio Brown do you want me to  call you Antonio Brown every single time  you sound like a girl how do I sound  like a girl you sound like a girl not  answering questions I don't owe you no  explanation but dog you came on a  podcast to not answer questions that's  not the way to ask them like you won't  mind to answer them that's no no no you  said you said I don't want to talk about  Kanye you said I don't want to talk  about something I ask you questions  about people that I don't know go ahead  ask me a question you ain't got no  questions for me to actually like  exactly because you're on our podcast  we're asking you the questions and I  gave you the answers no you said I don't  want to answer that that was the answer